this episode of zdenka Stubbs is brought
to you by red fox doing Buddhist
traditional throat singing Oh uncommon
Elizabeth very spiritual I I feel I feel
I feel at peace yeah and it's here yep
you're like completely free of all
worldly desires no I don't have any
material needs I wasn't doing a lot of
bets of my gone right now yeah do
mitsuba vana and give everyone I know
Spooner's am I Eightfold Path game of
the coin that all Noble Truths all one
two three four of them or no would
choose me so noble soldier welcome to
Dhinka Stubbs cultural commentary and
comedy about you buy em Jerry wow this
is this very official yeah it's great
welcome back to to Frank as tubs I just
want Frank as tubs to be our
spokesperson yeah it's like just just a
guy you have to find a guy named Frank
guest tubs and just be like we were
doing a fungus that sounds like you we
want you to sponsor us will you do that
that's think if your name if if you come
across this podcast and your name is
Frank s tub we got water when S stands
for but just send us a picture of you
yeah I like each week we want to feature
a different Frank esta richer franca
stubbs would be just a massive like
roly-poly Howard Taft's looking guy in
like a pencil stripe soup with a tiny
[ __ ] bowler derby hat either that or he
would look like Frederick Douglass like
Frank yeah I can see that like you know
it would just look or you would look
like Redd Foxx but dress like Frederick
Douglass in like period garb yeah
exactly yeah and and joining us today we
are our resident our resident a bag of
tricks yeah bag of tricks and you got so
many voices up your throat sleeve oh
stop it you just guys you guys aren't
even gonna know which which of these
voices the reel him in which which
famous figure were actually here with
actually Aaron and Jerry don't really
exist we're both just Mike or just Mike
voices welcome to mike mike is mike is a
very dear and close friend and a
resident animation expert not to be a
not to none we're actually mortal
enemies we're gonna fight to the death
hate him well okay but that I ever push
know what would Frank
was it Frank s toboy sound like Frank s
times i usually do like a hillbilly
would it be like us like a like a gruff
I imagine him it's like a boss tweed
type of character but I hope this was I
gonna be because any is their boss audio
you like any reference audio reference
of boss tweed ibly sound like see I have
no idea I kind of wish like damn that
Thomas Nast in his cartoons my dream for
this but actually about that son of a
[ __ ] ahead Frank a ship yeah yeah yeah
that is good another name got some more
swampy version or Frank s types that
your name all of you viewers at home who
are listening to this watching the video
watching the audio um right in and let
us know which version of franca Stubbs
you like do you want boss tweed do you
want like turn-of-the-century steel
magnate french franc tubs or deal with
ya blue do you want the Battle Damage
very heads-up Frank tubs in us yet I
just want the baby to frog frog giggin
Frank a stub I feel like that would be
part of the charms like eventually if we
have this machine up and running well
enough like every day episode would come
with like a 30 to 60 second animatic of
a different Franklin stuff in a
different kind of animated movie I feel
like we're all repeating way too many
demands on our resident this is late
notice down the line and when we can
tire is that when we have like an actual
microphone ok and a staff you know it's
like we can have a night of French more
guests Marc Maron interviewed the Obama
in his in his grandma's garage I think I
think did get what I really want to know
is about that any of your like so
there's just a normal garage you know
they're just like I mean he lives on
there like cars and Secret Service been
lining the outside of this just I mean
what are the neighbors like oh the
neighbors telling the presidential light
where motorcade outside and line 15
Secret Service guys haven't broken rice
place is it doesn't have like this is
ian like a nice part of highland park
like a spacious garage uh Rommels
Highland Park is like is kind of like
the van nuys of Glendale pasadena like
really yeah I mean I Highland Park is
that is that city you keep hearing about
on the radio worth like it's on the ride
like people are moving in and starting
to gently but it's still more errand
yeah but it's still but he's been doing
this podcast for a while I think what's
a town called Highland Park highland
park yeah it's not like you're only bit
I've only lived out here for like three
years I still don't know like what it's
kind of like a bottle and below Pasadena
yeah what's that kind of it's your own
legal rock yeah yeah it's kind of an
eysie okay it's kind of a nice what it's
with like kills isn't it like this Van
Nuys one of its marketing things is
that's completely flat yeah I mean it
does all really jealous hey guys is
totally flat man dies is the king of an
Isis flatters yet island no Robin
Parker's got hills yeah it's rolling got
mad he'll hella Hills rolling a hell van
nuys is the Kansas of LA it's like the
Kansas because it's for just for the
city limits of an eyes it's just totally
flat yeah and there's a lot of climbing
I'm still in awe of mountains and palm
trees because I've only lived out here
for a few years and they the only
interesting Geographic like landmark in
New York Long Island is the horizon okay
so it's kind of nice to see mountains
and but can't you see like the sea no
we're at sea level they were not up to
high so we don't really just literally
just walk out in this ocean oh the ocean
like sneaks up on you mix up on you like
it did in hurricane sandy oh yeah just
snuck up on let's say 10 or drink
where's this thing that lives right
around us what's it doing here it's like
oh man it's like yeah those terrible but
yeah it's frankest when wooden one in a
city on an island that's surrounded by
water it gets like swept up in a storm
that land just like it's flooded I can't
help but like kind of imagine that motif
in BioShock we're just like this is city
underwater and now the water is
reclaiming the city it's like the sea is
claiming what you what you built to
spite it I don't know why I feel like
for every video game reference we should
have one of those like old tiny clown
horns just like like oh yeah yeah I
don't know why I feel like turning this
into like a morning zoo yeah which like
every video game we gotta go we gotta
get that thing that they using cake to
make that like really quick like
sound yeah oh what what it's like that
weird springy thing where there's the
wooden ball on one end in a cowbell on
the other you smacking the ball vibrates
against the car yeah what is the name
for that thing I have no idea that's
after you're done decide the offers of
frank s tubs you want no there's guys
know what the name of that i was like
every time I was like cuz like Frank has
tubs is such a versatile name it could
be anyone under grab a bucket yeah you
know that he could be like a shitty
public access TV commercial having
lawyer like I have Frank a stuff hi
Frank a stops here telling you hadn't
your free money to pay your bill like
Frank a Stubbs has his own barbecue
sauce recipe that he's on the label of
the he says Tom and like the frankest
tubs would make barbecue sauce yeah for
a soldier for Franco Stokes barbecue
sauce is better than cooked exactly see
Franco Stubbs is a well of characters
that name just can be so many people are
we gonna talk about breeze talking about
Frank this episode a guest Stubbs is
brought to you by Frank s time Frank as
temps I just I'm paying for this episode
so that we could talk about the many
many men he hypothetically gets yeah
he's there we go that's for every video
game room no that should just be for
every time we say Frank s tubs that's
more my flagship thing what's the secret
word Frank SS tub subs area we got it
down we've activated if anything that'll
just make a stop saying swim you know no
I might get to mildly part of the cannon
I was into this episode of comedy bang
bang and based like someone slipped up
in and it was Jason manzou because he
slipped up and said course instead of
saying hang on man he slipped up and
said hey novel man and then every other
minute in that episode everyone was just
like addressing each other with a hey
young man hang on hang on man hey no man
it's just like it was like an hour and
10 minutes and I feel like eighty
percent of it was popular with hang on
man hey man that's the bread and butter
of like all so it's like when we went
out as latching onto one joke and be a
[ __ ] out of his that Joe like that
is always look like the Freudian slip or
the yeah like I heard one of there was
an old recording of them because he's to
record rocky boy uncle live and the man
and the police audiospice attacking the
place that rocky and boy cool it was
called frostbite falls and the now she's
like back in frostbite balls boss fight
balls and you just it's great it's on
YouTube it's a whole thing and all
cursing at each other like god dammit
you ruined the take sorry [ __ ]
frostbite balls moving on Leslie less
rocky boy collage [ __ ] god damn it god
just imagine all these like 40 year old
grown-ass chain-smoking men because it
was the 60s just like getting so
flustered over these bill like cartoon
critters Oh Michael and [ __ ] frostbite
falls sounds like a like a like a metal
band you tried to start with age 14 for
a challenge show oh yeah you just picked
like an ailment and like something you
thought was crude like you been we're
gonna do that we're gonna play better
the pants would be you gonna play drums
and we're gonna be frostbite balls it
frost my bones you say balls and dick
balls frostbite balls really gonna scoop
the word balls on your team balls yeah
frostbite balls sounds like it would be
some guys scrawled in like a page of a
Kurt Cobain no bulky what I just we used
the phrase frostbite balls yeah it just
episode is rich with potential title
yeah might just call this one frostbite
balls guess those fight balls yeah um no
it just doesn't sound like having seen
montage jpg does not frost by bone
sounds like something that would be like
in one of those notebook pages of Kurt
Cobain's of like a potential nirvana
when Jesus frostbite balls I mean like
how many times did Kurt Cobain write
about aborting Christ yeah like that was
a that was a recurrent theme in his
writing he used those two words together
time and time again I just think
frostbite all sounds like we're people
who climb on ever escape I don't happen
well yeah you got the frost bug on sad
case of frostbite falls worst case I've
seen this year
they're blue it's got who bothers you so
they're literally they're completely
separate Alan no because frostbite I
mean you did have Lulu ball ball time
cuz you know it's like you're not gonna
be [ __ ] on a mountain yeah these ABS
I'm a mountain dr sex with you no oh no
we'll have sex when you get back I'm
really busy right now well this blue
balls got frosted today then cuz I mean
frostbite a message has lost all color
like they saw the blood left yeah after
a while the term frostbite falls is
going to not make any more sense lost my
ball problem is that all that like all
the dankest dank ass stuff seen out now
I can take my guest hubs all the day
gets dubs merchandise it will be like
struggling government [ __ ] well the best
part is across white balls t-shirts are
also my guest tubs t-shirt bra white
balls truck nuts hey they're painted
like no they like their clear
transparent via the reso and they've got
our Facebook sparklies in it yeah we're
like glitter and suspended it like a
little like fake ice at this point if
you get any merchandise for this thing
and if you have any typos it's like
while I was in the show I guess no
episode but didn't I guess yeah it's
becoming a reality because like real
rejects is going to start having
memorabilia Oh once so dankus dank asks
Stubbs might just as well right so
frostbite balls hashtag frostbite balls
let's start a hashtag I know our sex
prescribed ashtag frostbite more off
frostbite balls tweet your hashtag
frostbite balls i do my twin a shout out
that sounds like I mean the frostbite
falls just sounds like 15 minutes it
sounds like a like it's like a treat yes
yes sounds like if you want an ice cold
treat on those hot summer days get a big
old box of frostbite balls let me write
the little balls I can't wait to your
mouth icy frost have you ever had you
have to have the the like a mascot
character has to be like a Yeti or
something but we're ready we like it if
rose by phos coming play Oh have you
guys ever have you guys ever seen dips
like little ice cream yeah I was bad
talking about those scissors because I
dibs yeah it's like frostbite balls to
me sounds like if like Spencer's gifts
had a frozen food section because I mean
Spencer's gifts cells like you know
stupid like yummy yeah like stupid gummy
candy you're like noodles that are
shaped like penises imagine imagine if
they had a frozen food sections
frostbite balls would be in the frozen
food section of Spencer's gifts they
would be dibs but with like a coconut
coating like little coconut shavings to
look like calling balls like the whole
yeah and I feel like the ice cream
inside would be blue it would have to be
a like this blue food just doesn't look
good yeah it could be a little light
blue yeah looking what can deflate yeah
cotton candy and coconut yeah it's not
gonna chase it was in frost my balls
weren't for thought is it because the
novelty it's a Spencer's gifts like
you're not going to eat those gummy
talks for like the flavor cuz they're
probably not very good I would theory
that I nobody actually uses anything
they buy at Spencer's goose yeah I can't
remember who was with someone like there
was like some philosophers those
basically just like don't own anything
in your house that is not beautiful or
useful and Spencers gives pebbles and
things that are the opposite of both the
vitals I had a friend in high school
used to steal thnx for Spencer Gifts
like we would literally go to the mall
come on really I want that because it's
like to yield what aren't you stealing
it's like it's not a [ __ ] like the
Tootsie Pop owl bell buckle like like I
can steal I can see stealing something
from an oz but like not a sponsor's good
because I was occasionally like petals
in something that's you know you'll find
coal [ __ ] yeah there will be like fandom
merchandise and stuff that's like okay
to buy an oz like a neat teacher like
Spencer's and oz or not are not very
different except Spencer's it's just
kind of like they ratchet up the
obnoxiousness yeah more leering and with
a bigger sex toy section yeah if spent
but the thing is it's like the sex toys
& Spencer's gifts are not like to be
user to be like pranks oh I just yell
now I forget a hard night I never
thought I just said this but speaking of
sex toys yeah that is a magical way
is a new segment of dank ass stoves you
know sex to it with like frostbite balls
now sounds like like like a toy that you
put in the freezer and you're like hey I
got the Frostbite bolts so scishow it so
it's like reasonable so it's like kegel
exercise balls combine combine with like
a cold pack you put it in the oh like it
like oh yeah it's like a nice and hot
that you so it's like a good people
expect so it's like those it's like
those students that like have to rub
like a thermogenic liniment on
themselves to work out so psycho yeah I
need my joints to be warmed up so I'm
going to rub myself with like a
thermogenic paste before I live take
this your combined but it's that for
kegels I just I don't know I know this
is a part of my brain I never open then
I'm just thinking of like if you can
define a sex toy would skip it all right
with that thing you put around your
anger is yeah I staying at all this
counter all these balls it's been a good
around I'm just imagining like it skip
it in like a sex toy connotation like
I'm imagining basically just like like
an ankle restraint but you like not just
are you restrained but you have to play
a game to go with it like if you're in a
BDSM relationship and your DOM is like
I'm going to restrain you and keep you
jumping for a long period at a time
don't stop jumping don't stop hopping
with this thing tied to you don't stop
playing this obnoxious game that gets
tedious very quickly imagine like a sex
version of bapat like like like skipping
complete with the exact same screen as
when you walk up that could work though
how about skip it is like I don't
imagine anybody ever play with it for
more than maybe a good five minute try
before we're getting like or not oh yes
how about like elefun but for like
inflation fetishists oh god why aleph on
see butterflies everywhere watch them
come with just a cute little elephant
that you just like plug into a rubber
suit oh oh boy so like the latex is only
like the elephant inflates you
like don't attach to like a up the pump
this is uh I don't know why but
reminders trying to go I'm trying to
wrap my head around what you described
like we're wearing the suit and the
elephant plugs into you to inflate the
suit while you're wearing I so wish I
this is just a fright the phrase along
the l just in the fact that was it was a
big elephant in feliz see you that's
another t-shirt it's like the color of
astonish element wearing like we're
knocking camp soon and like a ball gag
just around loose around its neck and it
just hasn't inflates you and on his
chest he's got a little hammer and
sickle and it's isn't so that's really
elevates you I feel like somewhere on
there is like a teenager that's just
discovering like Marxist memes on the
internet is trying to like knock the
republican party but as as eloquent as
he can get it's just ad elephant
inflates you i just i just really like
this notion that like all the tank
Estelle's merch is like it's like really
weird and nonsense yeah it doesn't
really make sense and it's not really
indicative of the show it's just these
like weird motifs like I'm Rick like him
oh you guys when I when I worked on on
rabbit we had a wall whenever we were in
the storyboard room and writing shows
sometimes we just be talking just a word
would be taken out of context and so I
would say something really random like
did you do the do you have the scene
where you know bugs points the gun at
the clown or whatever it was and just
out of context look what the hell you
just say and we write it down in a
post-it and who said it and put it up on
the wall and by the end of the season we
had like 50 of them on a wall so that
just sounds like why like the elephant
inflates you like like Nixon on Nixon on
what was the show that he was on front
for us no that's not frost next there's
like whatever day my last show was
awesome I balls atop the Frostbite balls
oh my god look Michael Sheen in the
French are with yellow sock sock it to
me and then never went on the show went
on a socket to me oh ok I forget all
this is something I would know Oh
laughing he was on laughs and don't cry
Nixon was on laughing yeah Nixon was
Atlanta he just didn't know how to ask
that because it was the catchphrase for
sockitumi Haley I don't want to say it
was just you just see them on camera
looking
are to me sock it to me better so who
doesn't who does the voice of Nixon in
futurama Billy left ok I had a feeling
was Billy Weston animus does that last
Adam are because I mean I feel like
Billy was just viciously shaking his
head whenever he does Nixon rubber baby
buggy bumpers she's real I am NOT a
Christmas you just really feel the jowl
motion in Billy West Nixon I think one
of my favorite lines he said he that he
that he was riddled with phlebitis which
is what is like I don't look at videos
if you if you watch videos of Nixon like
archival footage of Nixon he didn't talk
like that I remember you saw the jewel
you saw the jowls and like working but
he didn't actually sound like he was
just like Wiggly in the face I'm kind
about that Roth firing are very very
just kind of like a little like a gruff
Christopher Lloyd yeah I remember every
better better than I way unless I don't
know why but he just sells oh she's
gluck it grew up Chris harder little
Marty more we got a future after the
hoops are my daughter those are mine I
remember this episode i gaston's brought
to you by Nixon impressions Nixon more
negatives is brought to you by a lot of
things and I hope they all become
t-shirt why do my tube in throat
something red fox we we have we've come
up with so many like Lionel and current
motifs that all could be very different
things and I hope you know according for
barely 20 minutes we've already caught
up with for my blog frostbite balls
frail the tub I guess up the elephant
plays you isn't and new new media new
media creatives please I pires we know
how to make brands there engage in I
beats write them all down just that idea
just took a tumble down a flight of
stairs I mean I do the brand's now I'm
just obsessed with talking like Nixon is
it just as fun to me who is anna loosens
up my head my neck don't shake my hand
as i said i remember if i may break the
fifth wall for a moment i'll pay Erica's
in the room with us she's done our
magnificent drawings um for our
uh what we call the Mad Max obsession
with Jenkins road I guess road dang
guess road and our and our new
animations for the dank ass tubs i will
pay you people money i will pay you X
amount of dollars American if you
artists render the bondage elephant who
inflates and the Yeti whoever ties is
frostbite balls how do how the biggest
widow yeah we saw the coming at this I'm
gonna do we can edit together just a
slate of all our fake ass sponsors how
about everybody submit what you think
frostbite balls are yes realize the ones
that we've measures on the world cousin
I lost my ball and the one that wins the
most the one that gets the bets that we
like them are you guys like the most
because I'm not on the stamp show you
know you're on the show right now right
now gonna be on don't confuse the
listeners in terms of reality I've [ __ ]
but like yeah and then whatever these
two Mike this is going so well you will
be back I kind of water I kind of want
unless you don't want to compel
obviously that okay I just don't know
why are you enjoy anything so far unless
you sabotage this episode like yeah like
10 minutes from the end of [ __ ] push yet
pure over a pendulum going over set
everything on fire if at the ninth hour
of this recording you suddenly like
break down on the hyper racist diatribe
God you know I feel like the only way in
which in which mike could really
sabotage the spirit of this show yeah I
really the only way I could actually
sabotage the spirit of this show is if
he sticks to one topic and complete
every thought instead of having like to
go off on circuitous tangents and
changing the subject subject over and
over again the only true way I could
think of right now that I could sabotage
this podcast right now your iced coffee
or mostly melted ice coffees right here
i could just be like whoops don't [ __ ]
with my cuffs I'm not gonna love what
your call may just coffee it's a good
call here I'll trust your in my coffee
you were threatening the boys coffee
site i'll [ __ ] with my coffee there's no
Bobby you can't [ __ ] with my coffee what
the [ __ ] are you talking about the [ __ ]
are you talking about out of my house
you look me in the eyes and you [ __ ]
with my coffee how [ __ ] dare you
stupid son of a [ __ ] you don't talk
with a man copy it's understood I will
kill you with my nose and how angry I am
I will personally kill you with my I
don't know how I'll do it I'm just gonna
go over there and I'm gonna I'm gonna
shoot [ __ ] out my nose and hopefully
it'll embed into your [ __ ] skull that
would be a horrible slasher movie just
like Indiana is New York now the
question I asked my usuals no stoolie
out to you now the question i asked the
elephant inflates you that what happens
when that elephant that is our monty
python out it's like if ever we do is
sketch and we don't know how the
elephant inflates yet that's always the
end of the black all right um yeah I
feel like the elephant inflates you one
posed as a question it's it's what would
be said in one of those like board
meetings that took place in big when
they were trying to figure out what to
do with these toys like the guy who says
I don't get it it's just like I don't
get it so the elephant inflates you
that's it why would a robot turn into a
building lyssa which is a pretty
legitimate question yeah it's like why
would a robot turn to a building why
would a building turn to a robot like
now you don't want your building steer
skyscrapers to like start animating and
tearing off the other skyscrapers so
fight the aliens da this is a story
meeting for a Michael Bay movie right
there anything is welcome more flies as
I just assumed it is for more explosions
out of that will solve it there's
something we also have a fifth person in
the room is Emmett he's a dog what's up
dog haha we always worried to get you
that box playing bitty ones the dog and
there's also popular colloquialism in
which people refer to like familiar
people and friends dog you know it's
like where my dogs at not like k9 dogs
but friend dogs people like dogs man's
best friends it sounds like something
you're making up you know what go go
check out some culture
all right it's good it's good water is
your water brought to you by Frank at
Stubb's down down home water hey was
look there was there were once frostbite
balls for the smell trip yeah now
they're just drink balls freshwater
berries frostbite ballsonya tiny
freshest water babies as Tiny as like
waterfalls so they look like water
berries literally no that's water berry
juice is named from the freshest water
berries right fantastic well I'm sorry
Alan when we do the when we do the
elephant in plates you post your t-shirt
design till we do like the elephant
inflates you it's almost like like a
Stalinist propaganda Posey yes I just so
mentally beware of the elephant I want
so bayron elephant that inflates you I
want every version of all of the Arts
just like any any version of the
elephant inflates you I mini version of
Frank as tubs or frostbite balls I just
imagine the elephant just look at just
wearing like just a latex suit just
looking out of the viewer on the shirt
and just didn't expression like love you
know what I do yeah it'll be all over
dates you looks like so the opener is
all geared up or whatever fetishistic
actually gonna take place but is gonna
quite understand where you'll come from
and this outfit and does not still is
not a why the elephant really needed the
money and answered a craigslist ad and
so he's in this suit in the job at hand
was only vaguely explained to a man i
woke up with an elephant of my oh my smm
latex outfit what he was doing in my ass
and then lady takes out never know
that's an adventure right there that
that is a classic comedic bit that was
invented by Franco Stubbs oh yeah man
Frank has to I me shout out to Frank
because he's been writing our script
since day one yeah this is a none of
this is live we're all just we're all
just doing a staged reading of we're all
just doing a safe building of we'll get
to that Frank but don't worry rank is in
the booths to to be they said but there
are so many people in here yes there is
a a whole if I was repeating the wall
they all go in their breath for the last
25 minute if I was going so number
I would never rape the number of people
in a room but if i was going to number
the people in this room i would give the
crowd in this room in easy 28 out of 29
there's any 8 out of 10 yes there are 28
people out of this in this room the
maximum occupancy is 10 the feast of
maximum occupancy so I just love my now
we are quickly approaching the 30-minute
market and in like traditional react
filmic structure this would be about
when act 1 concludes i am going to act
to New exact to where we entered the
special world the new world of the
episode rochette and are not in our our
topic as we've entered this new world is
a smoothie smoothie it's a movie you get
it you're gonna keep it under its movie
it's a cinema it's a it's a magic film
it's in it's an illusion created by
still images like Hollywood phonies yeah
there they want you to believe that a
bunch of still images shown to you at a
quick speed is actually motioned when
it's not yeah it's just a bunch of
pictures liar yeah with light flashing
in between them dude light is such
[ __ ] you don't even I don't even
like no more light whose light yeah no
more light no more water that's my room
so we're talking about a cinema this
week it recently came out to the
theaters near you nationwide near you
yeah did read by my house if you live
anyone close to a movie theater this is
playing there yeah and I assure you and
obviously we're talking about battleship
yes uh-huh Mia highly acclaimed I to
lose these not be a gold existed well
you should have feel bad i'm still
waiting I'm still waiting for the hungry
hungry hippos movie I want what happened
to really Scott's monopoly when you want
to see a post-apocalyptic crossfire oh
god I have just found out
hey that Dwayne Dwayne Johnson's to a
rampage movie remember the video game
rental oh that's what is random asian
diet with from the giant 8 and the giant
lizard in there literally making I
assume Dwayne the rock Johnson is going
to be either the 8th the wolf or the
lizard I think he's gonna be like a
small-town cop that just happens to be
seven feet tall and seven feet wide who
has to save everybody from the giant
rampaging monsters how is how is this
rampage movie going to be different from
like a Godzilla movie but without that
Zilla I think it's probably be more I
mean if they treated seriously if it got
really say I we keep going off topic but
yeah yeah check out rampage in theaters
and eventually essentially the Duane
chat rocks check out rampage currently
in development at a studio were not
particularly near you you were saying
going to rock John so he's just like
he's all over everything like he's got
that new HBO shown that he's gonna
remake a not escape from your he's gonna
remake Big Trouble in Little China he's
in st. he's in that san andreas movie
that's out now he's also an uh she's
gonna be in the Disney movie coming up
next which one Oh Lana oh yeah oh yeah
he's supposed to sing which I can't
imagine I mean rockin to do it then that
man can do everything like oh and he's
in the he's in the new the remake of
roots it's gonna be on AMC what the
remaking roots why I got you yeah as I
said I wouldn't be surprised if they
honestly said ah people don't remember
that bruise I mean they could remain
written it would be relevant is this the
cultural climate where would be prudent
to remake roots ages I don't know don't
they would remake it but there have
roots for what is it oh no oh God and
then I don't like the Liz okay no it'd
be worse because it's like imagine if
they did to the roots what they did the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles okay we're
there which is what which is there
basically Kunta Kinte and everybody
there they're old CGI'd white guys and
they all still have like rap breaks and
that's right
forgot about that that movie was ok when
I was a ok but you waver at the end well
it was ok it was ok as [ __ ] it was one
of those movies where everyone's like
wha wha you're [ __ ] my childhood in
the brain and I'm like Assad I was like
this movie's fine Oh what's ok Chris
what I don't get is what is the change
be a ninja turtles current movie being
bad what does that do to the movie you
grew up with nothing cuz that movie is
not great either it's just you love it
because you want to stop like it's
cuddly like like I will say like it's
more cuddly because you know it was made
in the time war films were luckier a
little more genuine and also like those
animatronic sir how's the 80s so we were
more like a kin to let let's just
explore [ __ ] yeah exactly the zoo went
like i was last christmas i was a kid i
was that i proved at home to visit
family and I have a cousin who loves the
turtles really intuitive show the
turtles and he likes anything turtles
even the new movie but that's just it I
um he's like you know because he knows
that I I'm an artist he's like can you
draw Michelangelo and I'm like sure as
usual I started drawing like the 80s
turtles because that's the ones that I
remember as a kid with the eighties
turtle and then I know he's like no not
nuts that's not Michelangelo i said yeah
i mean i don't have an orange colored
pencil to shade in his bandanna but it's
him and he was like no I want like and
he goes into his drawer and he has a
bunch of toys that he got for Christmas
and he comes up with the action figure
of the realistic Michael Bay Turtles is
a goal this is Michelangelo this is the
turtle and I'm like I have to draw like
a super realistic with like and I put I
was with like way over designed when I
put yeah I put like extra effort at to
making sure his lips were all cracked
and he had like the hex under his eyes
weights do you take a picture of this
he's like five years old not even five
yet and his idea of what who the turtles
are or the Michael Bay turtles that you
gotta draw that Mikey and I'm like what
about that one the nice graphic looking
turtle over there he's cool and he's
kind of cartoony no I want the one with
like realistic pores and
we should not throughout the Nickelodeon
ones that are like more geometric yeah
like i like i like those designs in
charleston i like the eighties turtles
you know the play identical they look
more like the ice cream based off of
what they were supposed to be yeah then
they do actual you know but yeah but I
was really sad but I'm like that yeah
that's a new trend of ultra realistic
versions and friends that we grew up
with so that's what I'm engine rampage
is going to be just actual realistic
gorilla ultra-realistic Dinah lizard
ultra-realistic wolf that's giant
climbing buildings and causing
legitimate real destruction you know
what I was your nineties property i want
to see rebooting out for like realistic
gritty fashion but skeleton warriors
skels what nobody even remember skeleton
warriors it was like a zeal ischaemia
knockoff oh yeah i love these guys that
are not skeleton warriors these and
skeleton warriors never to me never
seemed like a real threat because it
just bottoms yeah so like you could just
literally roll things out no it's like
that's the tagline for the skeleton
warriors poster you see like the
skeleton borders just caught like
breaking [ __ ] and causing disruption and
the tag lines like this summer we're
both bad to they would literally make
the movie just based on like the tagline
is perfect we have to make a movie
around the 10 yeah if you had to make a
movie we have to make a movie because
there's so many stupid bone like on
genetically like an Adam Sandler movie
that just came out on netflix the
cobbler oh it was it just literally came
from the idea of like walking in someone
else's shoes literally took that erase
your out where it's a magic cobbler he's
a magic cobbler who puts on other
people's shoes comes that absolutely no
movie and it's like you literally just
saw like a comment like phrase almost
cool like don't judge a book by it's
cover I'm waiting for him to like just
what is summer Adam Sandler is the
bildungsroman you don't judge nerves
like the tiles like don't judge a book
by it's cover this summer Adam Sandler
is the novel and
awful as well as it's very close to that
southborough the rod rod minor interest
a dealership huge thank you yeah I got
to find that interview with Rob
Schneider in automated movie oh good
scallop mores your bad to the bone join
the bone-chilling action before it's 21
and of course at the time the big
tagline is bad football yeah cuz
everyone was super into George shoulder
oh girl good like ever the tag light
everything was either bad to the bone or
I drink alone I had to drink disc oh ok
so we saw you saw some cinemas so what's
up what is the cinemas that you saw I
guess toes oh we we saw the new pics are
joint cars seven car seven now thank you
lord Lassiter hey no this is pete docter
bro ya know ok yes and this is one
doctor who does make house calls listen
um no it was weird cuz we sought it I
know what theatre you saw that but that
the one we saw Pete docter did like an
intro to the movies what wha there was a
little clip if he's dr. be like we love
you please look our movie it was like
yeah we hadn't all had that too yeah
Mike didn't where did you see it we saw
at an undisclosed specific chain of
multiplex theaters okay was it the one
with the reserved seating it wasn't the
actual but i won Bridget salamat that
was really awkwardly named far inside
yes which is that I wouldn't name while
what was it called the Mulligan the
MacGuffin the MacGuffin bug which is an
assignment storytelling term yeah I know
it's like the big dumb object that
everyone wants which is going to be the
booze you bring into the doobie yeah I
mean it's not a better name for a movie
bar yeah I guess them guns it's a pun
about above movies and it also sounds
like you know it's like the old school
like family bar that's named after the
family that owns it yeah exactly the
kind of bar that Tom Cruise would have
created at the very end of cocktail Pete
and Moira MacGuffin news
Emmett that's a square a DJ it's you
just tried to dig through the carpet to
know where he tried to dig through the
ditches and a burn through the witches
and slam in the back of the shank you
love the dank EULA ah dude one day we
will have a dank you know that's all
around asanin times of merchandise we
need to make it like a Hot Wheels dinky
little match but I want to unite all the
the toy car the big four magnets yeah in
the hot wheels matchbox 20 you know
daimlerchrysler time well that they make
actual carmine Covelli toy cars now do
ya it's okay we'll get a dank EULA this
sure would really be cool on camera just
because you didn't need the [ __ ] we
would have we would have a camera on
each contributor and then we would also
have just like a room camera there's
just always tracking the other [ __ ]
going on this is thus it was the only
did you figure out what the show will be
like you know future five years from now
yeah we're this is our five-year plan
episode know so we saw inside out inside
out inside out out out out get out get
get out out get out don't go away don't
go away don't love you don't turn around
we glide through us ours in town no
inside out um four out of five yeah
anyway thanks for joining us guys yeah
this is our show so make sure to submit
your franca stub your frost by balls and
remember folks the elephant inflates you
anyway no no I take it we have all seen
this this cinema I have watched it from
beginning to end Wow well done even past
that it has a foursome to leave a bitter
sir it's closing time go so you SAT
through three of these we've let you pay
for two you have to go home listen I
just want to make sure that had a dearth
of material to talk about dearth a dirt
friend earth Fred third red doors and
who the founding member of smashmouth
Samantha hey I'm a big kid I have a
question for you working on wabbit the
same wabbit so many times
up the way you perceive the letter R so
like you startled say odd the word will
sing rabbit as much as we just say it's
other things rabbit is just the name of
the show and so what this times we're a
little bit like there'll be other times
where I'll start talking for the NSEL
pick up the impediments and the the
accents from the characters and start
don't home and start talking like bugs
or like forever else on the show so you
never have to worry though about like
you know just uttering you smile i'm
going to the break room like like it
doesn't going back home guys yes for the
uninitiated michael here is a Miss Gail
okay for the for the uninitiated man
well here is for the uninitiated here
Dharma here is a Dharma and Greg dharma
and greg cares waiting for you to add
the great yeah and now I got there I got
there but I wanted to keep the suspense
up like it's marcell cruised over here
is he is one of the contributing
storyboard artist for the upcoming Bugs
Bunny show wabbit yes it's going to be
on TV yeah that's all we're allowed to
say y on this TV network uh-huh it's
gonna be on your TV's coming soon to a
TV probably hopefully in your house
unless you're one of those people on men
and night yeah it's you're on it do
Mennonites have the tepees I know
Mennonites can have telephones or
fridges I would assume that a TV it's
probably like and probably multiple is
yeah I'm like point like my phone is
like there's a point to having one yeah
and you need the like you need the phone
for emergencies and like a fridge like
makes your life easier like a TV all is
just going to beam all the values you
don't necessarily want to drive with
into your house yeah it's like a phones
are useful to on a fridge it's like you
know that that pertains to like eating
yourself in subsisting nutrition you
know better better you know storage for
your food whereas TV is it's like fun i
gonna do this well I feel like you maybe
have access to a newspaper before TV
yeah so I know inside out inside out
inside out is not a good way to be but
it is a good movie to see ya just come
up with at the top here
yeah totally turn around he's wrong with
the punches and Jerry as tubs original
yeah that was that was a rhyme there's
some kind of rhyming Simon hey man I'm a
poet and I wasn't even aware to you
pointed it out to snap yeah he's a poet
and and though the years have off
designed to hide it Norton have to
reveal the talent he have been provided
all right you are poet no no I just made
some words of your a butt your butt your
butt we're but we're struggling to talk
about this film doesn't it would like
it's like no one wants to be the first
person to make an opinion the draw first
blood so mine okay I personally don't
done like the movie what whoa yeah on
the record on the record you're going on
record I'm going on record it writ writ
is my father's it is my final answer
that I thoroughly enjoyed this movie
final answer yes you're gonna what he
does like I regions always screaming at
people like somebody's not he never
liked shakes no no like knowing how he
talks he just literally is like a robot
yeah well from from what I've heard of
Regis Philbin's like backstage man or
he's not a good person oh no why you're
gonna go on record and say that I'm if
I'm going to go on record as to i have
heard things i don't know how credible
they are but they are from sources and
they're not good like I've heard more
I've heard horrible things about people
that I have worked with or cross paths
with in this industry that doesn't mean
I would name them well I mean Regis is
far beyond artist he's above our pay
grade yeah what I feel like the three
years from now I gonna have another
guest on your show I'm so I read your so
tell hope I hope you all the horrible
things that I've heard about you are the
true please say this on my fluffy ass
show floppy emulator that's great we've
come up with two new segments I forget
what the first one what was it speaking
of sex toys with my facing of sex toys
speaking of sex toys that's a segment
every every couple weeks i'd also i
asked me on the record you rip your
which is just like you know really quick
opinions about people
alright but yeah so this movie that we
were going to talk about do it it only
is good it was a movie I thought it was
very good yeah well made I like the
characters a lot and um it's better and
I'm gonna go all the records here sooo
it's better on the Rick then most of
Pixar's recent output I would agree yeah
I I mean taking the outside Mystic
couples taking an outsider since i will
say that i can appreciate something like
the inside out i can see the point to me
inside out more than i can see the point
of like cars too well i'll see if seems
like Pixar's crested into this new phase
in their in their life span world so you
had Pixar before where they would just
come out with a movie every few years it
felt like to maybe one or two years
Sally's felt like more than that well I
thought this is their 14th movie so yeah
like every two years to come out in the
movie yeah they would always like you
know that would be spaced out and and it
seemed like each one of them was you
know pretty thoughtful and from a
genuine place then we crest like after
cars we start to crest in this place
where it's like okay now they're fully a
piece of Disney so now it's like more
sequel so I figure out we get like it
like an every other sort of thing where
it's like okay here's a really genuine
one and here's the cars too and here's a
kind of genuine one and here's another
sequel if yes years 12 to you know keep
the keep the merch train flowing into
the lights on and here's one where yeah
we really just want to try and make a
good movie yeah and so i feel like i
like i did with things that i enjoyed
about the last few movies like little
things here and there like character
interactions stuff like that but like as
much as I might enjoy some elements like
I wasn't I'm not a huge fan of monsters
university or yeah even so even like
ones that are like really renowned like
toy story three looking back I really
don't care for toy story three see I've
missed a lot of their movies lately I
did see brave and I worked on the art of
brave book and the stuff that I saw of
that movie before it got changed was
amazing like and then it got kind of Chi
bashed know yeah what was I mean I
deliberately they said well they was the
method
oh gee that made those changes like what
well it's called firing the director and
changing a lot of things in the book it
was the point of honoring the director
well which well directors you should
continually it could be it could be
debated but there is a brain trust at
Pixar and there's a very very small
group of like their elite team and
anybody who's outside of that team is
less than so if there's a majority of
the people saying oh we don't like where
they're going with this movie just kick
them off they have it happens with
almost every other movie I'll be like
like ratatouille we're doing someone
else's really before Brad Bird to go
bunny facility when did it worked on it
for like a year and a half and end up
being where we end up seeing now that
new good dinosaur movie that's coming
out in November their trailers out for
now yeah that was done by a guy by
another guy and he got shit-canned
wasn't that I don't there's always that
story they don't like a good napkin with
only fire but wasn't that no no it's but
it's one of those cases where it's like
you're getting too close to your movie
we don't want you to get too attached to
your own idea and your own movies so
we're going to kick you off your movie
and make you sign a non-compete clause
so you can't work at any other studio in
Hollywood nobody's being made so I mean
is that too is that for the sake of like
they don't want somebody to get too
precious about the work that they're not
going to take down those are just like
their opinion of it they want the studio
control over the property first and
foremost and they don't want to have to
like lose any ground to of marketing is
evil dealer or marketing is a huge deal
that I'm making it on the market and
given what they develop including I
remember in the terms of like the story
telling us up if a person gets too
attached and if they get way too
attached to something they may not want
to give birth to it and they'll just
keep holding on it happens and I mean
all facets of introduction I mean that
one who is someone who loves something
too much or cares about something too
much as a point where they have to keep
making changes and it just doesn't move
down the pipeline it's like okay we
gotta jump start this thing again we
gotta kick off Oh get stuck into it has
to be perfect the bottom of the bottle
neck yeah i mean that's that's the
famous story of the thief and the
cobbler well the theme of the cobbler is
just you know Richard Williams is a
perfectionist and
we keep changing stuff because it wasn't
satisfied with it and then if you if you
have one person in charge for something
just so long and in the case of that
that started what the mid-60s and it and
it got taken away from them and like the
early 90s so about 28 years or 30 plus 2
30 years of production good [ __ ] yeah
there's a response to documentary
persistence of vision you will find out
the whole battery that's the name of it
the whole the little ray goddamn story
yeah um but yeah subjective whatever but
inside out did it start with Pete docter
was he always the building is always on
I think this film is on crispy dr. is
part of the brain truck yeah the doctor
is one of the main guys warned the main
brains yeah hashtag run it's easy to
remember but yeah it was you know you
know who says you know there's a lot of
changes if you get the art of inside out
book which we're looking at right now
yeah look at available at all stores and
quite a lot of pages it's many pages and
it's mostly art which is the best part
yeah there's not a lot talking you just
really spoil the store that's another
thing a few years ago there would be a
lot of art books and there wouldn't be a
lot of actual art in them yeah which
just kind of doesn't make sense because
this would be a lot of like just talking
just outside descriptions of things
going on and then like the thing that
pisses me off the most about art book
sorry animation art books is that they
very seldom show anything in the story
department like this no store very
seldom of their story board John it's
always like then and then some books are
just like they'll fill the book with
just renders of the computer it's like
you can watch the movie to see the
renders yeah see the final renderings of
the character I don't really need to see
like a grayscale untextured model of his
character i saw in full color or even
just the model they'll just ever turn
around of the bottle yeah and then other
other in other cases they'll just have
you know just a lot of the same clipart
you see over and over everything the
problem is like you look at an art book
and it's like what this is like this art
book here is like what may be like 60 or
70 pages not even let me actually flip
to the last page and see what the number
on it is on 175 that's significantly
over those you
I mean it's bigger than some of the last
couple of our books have come out no
this is 175 but that's think about it
that's only a hundred thirty five pages
in comparison to probably be thousands
of individual pieces of our head of the
bay for this movie that will probably
never ever ever ever see the light of
day and you're right i'm looking at this
now and they're there are there's like a
whole color script that's taking page
over like a six-page spread like there
is towards the back end there's art and
here that really does go into like the
entire duration of the story of of in
the conceptualisation obstacle i love
the color script whenever they put
college scripts entrada book it was a
great is a great tumblr that some called
uh oh is it like [ __ ] yeah it's called
on their funky i throwing barcodes oh
yeah and it's great because they compile
and it's very much like a color script
they'll compile a movie so like every
every two or three seconds they'll take
a picture and then it gets shrunk to a
thin line and gets compiled into a long
bar code and you can see the moments in
certain movies where was right or
wanting yeah like in Randy you see where
there's a fire you see where they're
playing in the snow you see where the
fall like summer is turning with the
fall because the colors are changing
what I think would be cool is if someone
who was really hot about like musical
theory could take it be that film bar
code based on the color of based on the
color of those different lines in the
bar code assigned a note to it and then
make like a piece of music based off of
the grand tones of the movie life like
if it was a like that team yeah
basically just kind of like make this
musical piece that's like all right
here's the red part of here's the part
of Bambi where there's a lot of red and
I associate red with this kind of sound
if I'm going to make like a little light
motif but based off of that redness here
in co 0 yeah so just make this big like
weird synesthetic experience words like
this piece of music is kind of like a
distillation of the emotional flow be
tired so way right now someone is
putting the domain down for a tumblr a
tumblr called here in collars man
cheering colors man colors I feel like
hearing colors is like the name of a
synesthetic like a message board for
people with synesthesia
also like to get I mean the man part I
like to inside-out a lot too and we
should start talking about the movie
yeah saying like what does it very liked
about it was that we didn't like about
it no it's not what we do on this show
bike so I don't know what you guys do on
the show no I actually really liked it
and I know that there are people that
have had like had like gripes and
complaints about it but it feels like
it's just it's a Pixar movie Pixar is
such a big trusted brand that you know
there's a hype machine that builds
around any Pixar movie and thats life as
you know cut by damaged a little bit
lately though yeah because now there's
just so many different there's so many
strong contenders that are going I mean
look at all the anime movies are coming
up this year yeah you don't have to go
to Pixar to get your fix other animated
studios are kind of rising to the
occasion of making good product but pics
are also seems to to kind of fear back
and forth between stuff like this and
then cars to more seal or they just
announced toy story 4 which is very sort
of worried some good ones like why did
we need that we I thought I think the
thing I like about inside out is that
it's just it's a it's an idea that yes
it's there they take liberties with
things but at the same time or it
doesn't it doesn't bring up as many
questions as say if you watch cars more
like okay why does the car is work like
yeah how does the car have a desk I did
a commentary with a friend and we
literally for two hours about the whole
movie just literally asked why for
everything that happened okay the cars
jogging passing as a mattress on its on
its roof and one eye to it and so I get
it cuz people you know people tie their
mattress to the roof it's like wait a
minute there are no people in this world
why would that car have a madness on its
roof what was the purpose of it and
another thing who tied it to the
mattress and how does he get it off when
he gets to wear but he's going like just
that that's literally a two-second gag
in a two-and-a-half-hour movie and I've
already asked three or four questions
now we're in find this commentary Mike
it's on I think it's on bandcamp okay
it's the I can't remember the name of it
but I'll it well I'll find the link in
17 years well will we will annotate the
video or put it in the description yes
but um mental note but with with inside
out it's like they're not it's so much
better that they did it the way they did
rather I'm like oh we have to travel up
the ndu Gabon Ghana into the cerebral
cortex and go to the UK
as a part of the brain it's all like
just figured like an imaginary suggest
suggested at subsonic just objective of
indica representations of parts of the
brain abstracts a lot you know that
anybody can access it like a you know I
feel like the older you get the more
you'll appreciate and understand certain
things but yeah this is strong in a way
we're like a kid could still latch on to
and the only thing and the great thing
about is that the educators and the
thing that's what makes a great animated
movie in general especially for like
disney walt disney thought of it this
way where it's not about aiming because
if you look at any of the old disney
movie so like when Walt was alive which
is it sounded it's not a really a true
fair comparison because our society has
changed so much since the days when Walt
was around making movies when I was 200
using that was yeah that was you know
back when the dinosaurs alone but one of
years ago but you but the thing is like
they never thought about demographics
because that was not marketing was not a
thing they thought about on the bay
boobies absolutely no you don't like
Cinderella is not made for girls they
don't know hater the movie two girls
just like they don't cater Snow White to
girls or Bambi two babies or Dumbo two
babies or Alice in Wonderland to search
going in that baby market you're not
there baby money baby money but like if
they're universally accepted movies an
adult can enjoy just as much as a kid
and the thing about inside out is and I
think there's a lot of moments in the
movie that kids can latch onto an easily
kind of grasp on and laugh and have
funny moments then as small as in the
movie where you know it's a very adult
Joe but even they made a reference to
Chinatown yeah there was a Chinatown
like cultural reference and I know that
something has been Robert forever is
like oh yeah we're gonna make a cultural
reference for the adults but as far as
the humor and inside out something that
struggling was like there was a
subversive edge here and there like you
guys caught the bear joke yeah oh you
have a bear Joakim in San Francisco yeah
so guys it's like a bad it's like guys
are really hairy guys if it's I think of
where you are yeah in San Francisco so
like there is he there's a joke about
like the bear community one of my
favorite jokes in the movie also is the
one where they knock over a box to
December vaca time
I mean is wax you go nowhere I get those
mixed up all them ahhh ya pile them all
together in a box yeah yeah it's great i
love just like this moments like that
and this is a little easter I'm gonna
shirting abstract like I love my fifth
one of my favorite it's not even an
easter egg someone whacked out after I
thought yeah it was really cool that but
that once I remember it just as an
easter egg for me as a filmmaker like i
love i grew up with the Muppets along
with Disney movies hmm dude there's two
guards that are blocking some
subconscious yeah one of them is voiced
by Frank Oz who was in all ways Yoda
Fozzie Bear animal and the director of
Little Shop of Horrors yeah and the
separate wise would make him that Brando
movie where Brando just made fun of him
all the time offset yeah why then and
the other guy was Dave goals who plays
gonzo but now played opposite so the guy
who's Dave played Frank and Frank play
Dave and so just seen he's just been
playing themselves as these two cards
that's my hat no my hat does the same my
hat in the head like I thought that was
really a just there was some really fun
like little moments where even as a like
someone took like natives I'm not into
film like I don't know every aspect of
film with a history of film but to me to
be like a big Muppet fan where the big
doctors also a huge bump offense I mean
obviously look look at car from up he is
like you know the guys in the balcony
yeah like you should be like whoo
Statler and Waldorf illegitimate love
child child yeah yeah but yeah it's you
know he's a huge fan of the Muppets and
it's clear in the design the designs of
even though even the the designs of the
different characters in the movie you
are very Muppet life like anger is very
Muppet like fear is extremely Muffet
like yeah fears like very gonzo ition is
designed yeah and you know they don't
kind of look they have that like fuzzy
and the dad I have a cool I think that
your paint yeah like yeah they do have
like that that texture to them which I
don't quite understand what that's
supposed to represent I guess the fact
that they're just figments of your
imagination but they are that there that
there are some subconscious thing and
kind of fuzzy yeah this is sense there
was sort of made up of some other [ __ ]
it's like everything in the real world
is very like you know concrete concrete
and and the Lions are sharp and you know
so you have these brain that's why it's
going to be weird seeing people draw
these characters because it's like
something isn't right about it as a zit
on a fuzzy outline i made them to smooth
what it almost seemed just like they I
don't know that I could be completely
off but it was just it seems like they
decided to keep it more and plug it into
your visual quality to separate the two
yeah and another thing like I just just
the fact that they make all these great
design choices in the movie like the
filing the fact that they're kind of
fuzzy and I like the fact that even I
mean someone brought it up to me and I I
can't think it see her without thinking
about the fact that joy has the same
exact color scheme as Marge Simpson yeah
that's it's hard for me to get over just
can lu hair yellow skin and a green
dress yeah it's hard to get over um and
looked as if there was red on her feet
that would just be way it would be like
seared into my brain Oh sadness Oh I
thought of it this way like be happy and
this problem reaching what I see if you
look really closely it kind of like that
texture that all the emotion characters
have they come we were like balls and it
reminds me of the ways in which like
neurotransmitters are shown in in like
different textbook diagrams I remember
as a high school editor built their made
up of a lot of little pieces made of
like little pieces so it's almost like
these are like the incremental like
molecules of serotonin or whatever
oceans are made I don't know that was a
big night I know what was very
interesting that you pointed out is like
the emotions are all based off of a
specific shape of something ya like like
San this is a teardrop silam yes
Edison's teardrop anger is a break
measure there's a like a mortar brick
yeah um discussed ISM is a broccoli yes
broccoli and that's really clear if you
look at someone like the earlier designs
of disgust in the art book yeah the
dress throws it off because the dress
flares out on the bottom which doesn't
make it I guess from the dress up it
looks like broccoli yeah in the hair it
kind of kind of ugly suburbs the Paris
see ya and then like and fear supposed
to be like a nerve ending yeah like it's
linking the axon yeah he's got like that
little cord at the top of his head up
your hair thing enjoy this is like a Joe
is like a tool if she's like a flower
that's that hasn't got it yet a bud
and um I mean it's great i love design
choices like that I just like the
character design choice or like the
design of the performance like yeah
who's black was the perfect guy to voice
anger yeah but yeah like Bill Hader was
fear yeah yeah yeah we talked about this
bill hader was playing here like he was
a young Wallace Shawn haha sounds like a
young sure hey it's like a subtle yummy
all that exact and it really works it
really is well yeah i think you know cuz
there's there's there's the argument for
a number of times over animated movies
and voice talent lately and you know
like a lot of people are getting better
about it but it seems like a lot of the
earlier dreamworks movies and stuff like
that let's put celebrities husband like
this this five core characters that the
make of the emotion seems like they
really chose the right people with
expressive voices with imagine they
lived i mean when they watch these when
they when they do casting the directors
are sitting there thinking of like who
would be a perfect course of this
character and they think about things in
their mind like oh I know Amy Poehler
would be greatest anyway and Amy Poehler
even though she's she's a household name
egos of Parks and Rec and in her ass and
Eleanor 30 rock days was like the thing
about Amy who looks like she's really
like joy is so in her wheelhouse she I'm
really good at playing to be the apple
like really kind of plucky and likable
but sadly kind of like a Bolivia's all
like almost narcissistic way too
optimistic person one and I've heard it
said before that like at least in
comparison like I between her and Tina
Fey like Amy Poehler has a bit more of
an empathetic and a more kind edge to
her comedy in general like even in the
delivery to like Tina Fey can play look
at me I'm a mess like the liz lemon joke
about Liz Lemon character in 30 rock is
like she's just kind of sad in kind of a
mess and but even the outward comment is
a little more skewering when it comes
from Tina Fey and it's a little more
like no no but we've all been there when
it comes from amy poehler's there's like
a softer edge yeah on the empathy and
then the Sun you know like I'm trying to
think of what else in the movie by I
mean the big the big thing like also in
the last couple drew
DreamWorks the last couple pics off pics
are things I there hasn't been like a
real tearjerker moment in them yeah this
movie this movie beats the [ __ ] out of
Binoy emotionally but also the thing I
love is going to see the movie like this
with an audience I mean seeing a movie
with an audience is great audience
reaction to me it makes it makes a big
part of our experience but the great
thing about this about this movie is
that there's great moment for the whole
audience is dying laughing and then
there's moments where you literally are
sitting there and you're literally
hearing yeah I haven't I haven't heard
better jokes in a Pixar movie or just
like ever like jokes out-landed better
in a movie in a while it's like yeah
sometimes you'll be in the movie and
you'll hear people around you laughing
at a joke and you'll be like yeah but
that doesn't really feel earned you know
yeah it was like we're just kind of
reacting in like the joke wasn't really
that great yeah but you know and they
don't say hear the jokes about the last
felt earned and the sadness felt earned
yeah that's if there's a good bowels
between the humor are endless and but
you know the sad no it's too emotional
moments more soft I think that the when
it all comes around the end I think
that's sort of a nice sophisticated
message to throw out there do nowadays
because everything now is very much like
it might not be directly about this but
you know joy that's very prevalent in
society now just in the social sphere
it's like everyone has to be happy all
the time and decided you forget the
other say like even if you're sad people
sick smile go on smile you happy dammit
it's like even though your heart is
pretty your body though it's aching but
yeah Oh God well you make worth wait
were you making an achy breaky heart
reference no modern tummies smile though
yeah it is oh geez yeah I'm so happy
you're the Charlie Chaplin fan out of
all of us have a lot of times cafe use
me oh speaking of um good casting I
can't remember the name who did Bing
bong but all Richard Conte original kind
yeah that's funny great character actor
yeah in fact he was in a Pixar movie
before which one he was in bugs life it
was us he was the villains like his
brother or sidekick Oh
the nervous shedding molting both of
things yeah guess it's why you can call
them all because he Malta cousin in in
the bing-bong character I feel like he's
it's a subtle version of a character
that would really be good at voiced by
dom deluise yeah well I mean he's
figuring of Dom DeLuise a lot of people
but so my friends online said that my
favorite character and inside out was
was koosalagoopagoop yeah Miami models
like [ __ ] from you just imagine even
scream you say was a similar concept and
I maybe that's why I'm thinking Dom
DeLuise one yeah when we interact with
being able just imagine just walk across
train going but you but each other wow
you know like that gonna but he's a very
genuine heartfelt character yay in he
doesn't feel obnoxious and his his
cheery affable pneus that is never too
over the top and I guess maybe it's good
that he's voiced by someone who's
playing him a little bit despite how
ridiculous he looks and how like loud
his design is I think it's good a voiced
in a way that is not all out Dom DeLuise
yeah I mean it's unique in its own way
it's think it might be reminiscent I
mean it's Richard Conte who plays
characters like that before it's just
sounds very much like Richard thank you
like cuz I was I've been watching kimmy
schmitt a lot lately and there's a whole
couple em too 70s on and like the second
his voice came on like a second sample
he's he's pretty broken already but yeah
like he I mean like and also I I had a
discussion one of my friends and I saw
this movie together and we cuz I guess
we should say that there are spoilers in
this oh yeah they're always so nervous
for this but like it's always photos Big
Boss Big Bing bong is it what happens to
him is probably the saddest part of the
movie but it's also like a perfect and
uplifting thing to do with them because
it's like he is kind of like this
affable tram care he's an imaginary
friend that does not have a purpose
anything anybody realizes that he's that
what he's doing is gonna hold lightly
the girl back so he decides to leave
literally he's too much baggage he has
the room
joy to go on alone start to go on and
leave them behind in the immune all of
the dump but the thing is that I discuss
with a friend I'm like people are
literally going to see this movie and
they're gonna leave the theater and be
like I'm gonna remember you big bomb
like I don't know what you die well so
they're gonna go to the disney store and
they're gonna buy the bing-bong plush
which retails at like 20 or 30 bucks Oh
God and because it said I said I said
that at the theater I said that like
people are literally gonna flock saying
that we love this goddamn character and
they're gonna go to the store and buy
Bing bong toys and they're going in then
two days later she messaged me saying i
went online because i want a Bing bong
toy they are all more sold out none of
them none of the emotions not joy
sadness none of them at none of their
toys are sold out because what are you
gonna by making her toy for but like no
but we look like Bing bong you're grumpy
grandpa off the movie that that's the
keg & Co I mean look at anyone yeah he's
literally made of cotton candy he's pink
his fuzzy he's an elephant he's a hobo
elephant that's made of cotton candy who
does not want them in the house there's
less of a drive to because it's like you
know even even by the movies own you
know set of rules like everybody's got
an anger of joy a sadness and discussed
and a fear but but we all gave up our
veterinary friend like that'sthat's you
link back to childhood you left behind
so like I get why people would be like
Big long and Eve's you like it can I
just say something for a second maybe
i'm weird like this and i know if you
get our ever this from when you work on
your shame i'm weird a lot of ways um
but did anybody have an actual imaginary
friend when they were a kid oh I did
yeah cuz to me I feel like I oh I had no
free to meet hi I'm Emily I only had an
imaginary friend because I saw people
have imaginary friends on shows and on
TV and in movies I thought oh I guess
that's what I'm supposed to do as a kid
and I have to I have to make up an
imaginary friend I don't know I don't
remember if I did her I I know I but I I
my best friend otherwise was my VCR okay
movies and I because I know when you're
an artist and you're you know over a
little kid and you're not sure and then
it's the most artists start in one place
I may have had an imaginary friend I
don't think I ever had
one specific imagine over I felt like I
kept on changing imaginary friends
because I would see like imaginary
friends and like Puff the Magic Dragon
or in Dexter's Lab and I would go
through this process of thinking yeah
you know almost like almost like seeing
how other people were renting their
imaginary friends and think things like
oh yeah my adventure and Frank can't do
that only let me let me let me go back
to the lab and reimagine a new imaginary
friend my imaginary friends names chris
he's just a human boy yeah but he's very
wide yeah he's really he's like
comically proportioned live but other
than that I just did my question it
being bought like why is being born a
pink elephant did Riley have to get a
drinking problem when she was four
nation I heroin problem I think it's
just well I think they even say in the
mood she was really into animals oh yeah
and bind every animal that she liked and
cotton and cotton candy into that
creature I mean the same thing is that
characters so the design is so great and
it's so huggable looking you know any
toy that you get of him is not going to
capture that essence as it does in the
movie it's I'm gonna give him the cotton
candy tech yeah the cotton candy texture
because you can't can't that's uniquely
in yeah I wonder if they're any artists
out there who work specifically in the
medium of cotton candy of molding
cutting cotton candy and Jeremiah sure
oh I saw a video of a guy who makes
cotton candy flowers oh wow wow
different-colored uh what's on another
[ __ ] Bing bong hit put a little
shabby coat on him and give him to the
world no but like I really like that
just isn't overall as an overarching
message of a move because there's so
much pressure now to be happy all the
time had to cover up any like you know
especially the social media just all
about sort of like how my own ego
marketing yourself and drowning out any
dreary or unhappy thought with smiles
and activity and like you know yeah it's
a good reminder that you're like sadness
isn't is an important part of the
spectrum but saying this isn't doesn't
have to be a bad thing yeah exactly
something then everybody goes through
and so and you know it's it's not a bad
guy depression in the month is it like
and those original you're gonna have
like
gloom or depression be a bad guy
generally antagonist enn Tagus like rose
but they should not personify depression
as it shouldn't be a character should be
something that invades you yeah it's
something that everybody goes through i
will say like to be handled it well
depression does show up in the movie but
the depression isn't because like
sadness is running amok depression is
what happens to Riley went like the
emotional control console break is down
and she just can't feel anything else
going through a lot even in the movie
act like Santa says I don't know what's
been going on with me lately but I just
feel cuz I mean she feels compelled to
act yeah like right now she feels
compelled equis like Riley is 111 years
old in the movie and she's going through
this major change he had the big
medicinally sadness doesn't really serve
a purpose real I mean these are all I if
she said but now she's like I don't know
man that she suddenly has his inkling to
touch things and stuff like that like
gosh after 11 years now she wants to
touch these thought these thought forms
yeah and it's you know I think it's
interesting to see how I get it the
other and the thing I like about the
movie said yeah as a kid I guess I maybe
I don't remember it as well as merit
that well but to me I just remember
myself being just straight happy sad mad
scared disgusted and then when you get
older there's a point where it's you
hear this it's more complex emotions are
more complex it's now you're with
excitement with or with fear with anger
with this and with that oh yeah one
thing you unlock you know more complex
things like I imagine like a joy sadness
or together is like a nostalgia of some
kind you know cuz ya cuz I mean even
bing-bong as a moment exactly like that
word sadness but you descend this helps
you remember the happy times yeah yeah
which is and the thing is Pixar has that
way to or not it's not even hitting it
because it's not really hitting it on
the head it's easing into what the moral
is it by showing visual or showing
examples of the bat in the smaller sense
so like San is comforting Bing bong
afters rocket gets pushed off into the
dome yeah and there's a moment like
that's really sad yeah I remember all
the time so that it call it happiness
can't fix that yeah but having the
sadness validated and having the sadness
you know is it's you
connecting over and empathizing it was
somebody who said this is is you know
the kid also yes sadness can be
disappointment but it could also be
missing or recalling something that you
feel really something that really
affected you or even in a good way and
sounding that you know and acknowledging
sadness can can you no clue you into
things and wake you up Taylor yeah I
think it's really important because when
you really look at when really looking
at the structure of the movie there
isn't a single villain there is no
there's isn't any villain but he's not
losing weight though yeah yeah great
when there's a movie that has just it's
just difficult circumstances feeling
helpless like if you're going to say
there's an antagonist it's I mean I'm
sure like I'm sure someone who's you
know an academic and has strict
adherence to light fitting every
successful movie into like the the
strict react paradigm as me yeah I'm
sure sounds gross no sadness is the
antagonist but it's it's this other
structure is the buddy structure where
you know the antagonist and the
protagonist instead of defeating each
other they cooperate at the end I'm
thinking now let's shut up actually else
your ending is um status and joy have a
gun fight yeah and just get guns there's
a good good thing right by my house it
goes there's this place imagination as
the grip of a house I think it could
suppose elephant do lose he's got going
to rip in my house he's like so lame
he's kind of cool because he's like so
Liam's me a cotton candies me a cotton
candy and like yeah it went through some
just crazy designs for disco as if they
said that was the hardest character
design because the thing is like which
is weird because it's like she's not
even in the movie a whole hell of a lot
yeah she's probably I mean I like all
the characters in movie but of all of
them discusses the one that I believed
had like a like a like a way I'm going
for her job is to be like kind of a
pible but just like well not Apple but
you know you still like her but she's
just her job is just kind of be snooty
and Turner nose up at everything yeah
but she's more amusing than she is like
finding light and if you look if you
look at the art book your ends which I'm
doing you right now he's looking right
now you notice that like most of the
signs
up turn noses yeah which is a great
design choice but like you see Inklings
of like yelling some of these look more
like broccoli yeah it's more than these
ones look like broccoli this one's look
like almost like dr. Seuss characters
well most of them look like this is cool
oh yeah they all kind of do but she
looks like something I she looks like
something like that up with mr. Benge
yeah exactly that's what was going to
say with this one yeah and then there's
ones i can't see these yeah you can't
see them but there are one and this one
looks like looks like a girl version of
the gangrene gang from the Powerpuff
Girls yeah your York your curiosity has
been piqued if you want to hear or see
more about this this episode of tanked
estos is brought to you by the art of
inside out published by published by a
power uncle books conical books we're
not desert ever they didn't actually
give us money or give us money but
there's a finger was brought to you by
yeah I don't want to now turn turn him
into Garfield this is Oh little bad for
the uninitiated and we are invited can
Mike to turn anything into kerf if you
do a sketch of a line or do long piece
of paper Mike will find the Garfield and
all your the fine car fuel or if I'm
really really really out of it i define
goofy which is easier to find goofy and
things but Garfield is a challenge which
reminds me I'm gonna you can't see it
but I'm gonna actually have a piece of
paper okay Jerry's making making a line
Jerry Jerry Oh Gary's making one I don't
know wasn't in the show over the surely
been here for an hour and 20 minutes
sorry Jeremy now it's long enough you
guys keep talking I would provide all
Mike's doing that well wise little bikes
it one meanwhile Mike Scioscia is from
Garfield this is nice to be reminded
likely yes a healthy spectrum of human
emotions it's a good thing yeah and
especially apparently and this is
something that I've appreciated like you
know I saw a special screening of big
hero 6 with with Erica and the guys I
made big hero 6 said yeah we interviewed
people who are specialists and
counselors for kids to talk about what
brief does to kids and and we also
talked to the people who are specialists
and count and and you know researchers
are about robots who are trying to
design a robot like baymax you know a
hug
all home care machines the final robot
yeah vinyl robot you put it on your LP
player um give it a little spin on the
Victrola your vinyl robot you my name is
your what for technics or yes